Sharkboy and Lavagirl are back for an Avengers-style
sequel, but when they're captured by alien
invaders, a group of super-powered kids including
their daughter Guppy have to come together
to try and rescue them.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video we're diving into the ending of
We Can Be Heroes to reveal all the secret
clues you missed that set up the movie's big
twist.
Obviously, spoilers ahead, so take care.
We Can Be Heroes initially tricks us into
thinking we're watching a pretty typical alien
invasion movie where superheroes will save
the day, however, at the end of the film,
we learn this has all be a giant ruse!
The aliens aren't here to openly attack us
but to secretly support us by training the
next generation of superheroes in the awesome
power of teamwork
so the super-kids can take over from their
parents and fix the earth's many problems
as soon as possible.
For their plan to work, the aliens infiltrated
both the government and Heroics HQ.
But it wasn't just the President's name, Neil
Anami, which is 'I'm an Alien' spelled backwards,
that pointed to the movie's twist ending.
A big clue to the surprise twist was also
hidden in the name of the aliens' home planet,
which was called Ogima.
If you spell Ogima backwards, it turns out
to be "Amigo", which is the Spanish word for
friend!
"A message from the supreme commander of the
aliens.
We are from the planet Ogima."
So, the fact the aliens were really here to
help us humans rather than harm us was predicted
right from the beginning of the movie!
Interestingly, writer-director Robert Rodriguez
also indulged in a bit of backwards naming
in the original Sharkboy and Lavagirl movie,
calling an unfinished robot character Tobor,
which is robot spelled in reverse.
Even before we find out the name of the alien
planet though,
there's another huge hint to the film's finale
when Missy sees Miracle Guy being wheeled
into an ambulance after the movie's opening
alien attack and, in an effort to reassure
her and stop her worrying, her dad tells her:
"That is just a training exercise, probably.
A… a 'what if'."
In fact, it turns out that everything Missy
and her super-powered pals go through after
this in the movie
is indeed a big training exercise organised
by the aliens to ready the kids to step into
their parents' super-shoes and save the world!
There are also several tell-tale signs as
soon as we meet Ojo that there's much more
to her than meets the eye.
First of all, she's not dressed like any of
the other kids, who are all wearing T-shirts,
jeans, and other casual clothes, in contrast
to her smarter white blouse and black trousers.
And that seems appropriate because, after
all, she is the aliens' Supreme Commander!
On top of that, her name, Ojo, is the Spanish
word for 'eye' and can also mean 'insight',
all of which fits her character perfectly
as she's all about vision and foreshadowing
what's going to happen, drawing things on
her tablet which later come true.
But that's not all; the word 'ojo' can also
be used in Spanish to warn someone to 'watch
out!' or 'look out!', which is also fitting
as Ojo isn't what she appears to be;
she's not a human girl, she's actually an
alien!
I love these little clues and extra layers
of meaning that Mexican-American Robert Rodriguez
gives the film by including Spanish words
like this
and the fact he continues to cast diversely
including lots of Latinx actors, as he's done
on many of his previous projects.
By the way, if you were watching like a hawk
during the scene in the tunnels,
you might have just caught the picture Ojo
drew of herself with her alien tentacles on
display which flashed by in a millisecond
as Missy was swiping past on Ojo's tablet.
And there was another sneaky clue that it
was Ojo who was really in charge of the aliens
all along when the kids discovered the president
on the alien mother-ship and overheard him
discussing the takeover.
"How long before the takeover begins?"
"According to the supreme commander, less
than an hour."
"Ever wonder why we bother with all this when
she already knows how it's gonna turn out?"
That's a reference to Ojo's ability to see
the future and a clue that she's the one really
giving the orders.
Did you also notice Ms Granada's rather odd,
exaggerated manner from the start which was
perhaps a clue to her alien nature?
For example, when she enters the Control Room
at HQ, she walks more like a model sashaying
down a catwalk.
And then, there's the slightly strange way
she often holds her hands out to the sides,
almost as if she's either performing a dance
in a musical or trying to keep her balance!
Maybe that's because of the mass of alien
tentacles she's having to hide in her human
disguise.
That the new Heroics kids can succeed where
the adults failed is also cleverly emphasised
throughout the movie.
For example, the many butterflies dotted around
Missy's room right at the beginning of the
film, symbolise the fact that she and the
other kids represent a new beginning, a fresh
chance to get things right.
While the rainbow on Guppy's necklace sends
a subtle message from the start that these
super-kids are humanity's hope for a better
world, as Ojo confirms at the end of the movie.
This new generation of heroes is all about
teamwork, rather than squabbling among themselves
like their parents.
And to accentuate just how different they
are to the previous generation, the new Heroics
also have an entirely different look.
Gone are the colourful costumes and hard-to-see-out-of
masks often favoured by superheroes including
many of their mums and dads, such as Sharkboy
and Lavagirl.
"All superheroes have costumes.
Pads, fake muscles, tons of useless buckles."
"Underwear on the outside."
"Masks you can barely see out of."
"That's why they were able to pick out our
parents so easily."
"We have to blend in."
Instead, those highly visible costumes are
replaced by more practical uniforms in muted
colours.
"So what are we supposed to be looking at?"
"The future."
There are also masses of Sharkboy and Lavagirl
easter eggs in the movie which you can discover
in my other video.
Tap here to watch that or follow the link
in the video description.
What do you think about the ending of We Can
Be Heroes and would you like to see more sequels?
Let me know in the comments below.
Tap left for all of my We Can Be Heroes easter
eggs, or tap right to watch something else
you're sure to like.
And if you enjoyed this video, a thumbs-up
is hugely appreciated!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!